okay I have to throw this out there
because I still see the wave in my head
kind of on a very two regular basis The
Perfect Storm it's part of why I'm still
scared of boats you know are you really
scared of boats well not like near land
okay but out in the water you're scared
that deep open water I mean what that
movie like screwed me up I remember we
were standing on the dock I was standing
up on the boat on the dock and you're
with uh Dirk Diggler yes yeah Mark and I
were standing up there and we had all of
these giant rubber swordfish because
Wolfgang Peterson he's a big animal
rights guy you know and so there's all
these rubber swordfish at Great expense
they made he was like we'll do the fake
fish and all these protesters like a
couple hundred of them come storming
down on the dock one you know shame on
you shame on you and Mark and I were
sitting up on the on the dock and I just
go they're rubber
oh and then they turn around
[Applause]